hey what's up everyone E
it's me Pete I'm Rob hey Rob hi Peter
new Zelda DLC is out we love Zelda so
we're gonna play that today which is
going to include a host of things a lot
of new armor we're gonna look for Rob
got started playing the trial of the
sword last night which is forty five
levels of difficult challenges that are
I don't know maybe a little bit like
Eventide island yeah very similar
definitely it's tough well we've got a
list here of what's new in the game so
let's click on over to that real quick
and stay tuned because we're gonna be
playing for a few hours at least
yeah I think our ultimate plan is we
will be getting all the armor I think
we'll then take a look at master mode
will so we'll have to start a new save
just for a little bit see how difficult
it is because apparently it's it's an
insanely difficult and then we'll end it
on trials and see how far we can get
yeah yeah alright so let's take a look
at the list of stuff thank you so we've
got the trial of the sword yeah we do
yes we do
yeah so basically this is gonna power up
your Master Sword if you can beat all 45
levels to the point where it what
doesn't run out of power basically and
it gets more strength added to it I
think I don't know about running out of
power I know that it's it increases to
60 so last night I played and we're
gonna start from beginning but it looks
like it's increments of 10 so you do
like the first 14 floors and you get an
item level of 10 increase so it went
from 30 to 40 so I imagine that there
are two more from 50 and then to 60s so
you take little breaks which is nice
because if you die you start over great
it's it's tough cool cool so so then
we've got master mode down here
so we know a few things about how master
mode works enemies are just stronger by
default they have health regen I'm gonna
turn the mics up a little bit mics up a
little bit so by that we're good we're
guys sounds good I think it sounds
better right
so master mode is going to have again
tougher enemies they can notice you from
greater distances away and they also
have health that regens automatically so
you don't beat them fast enough it's
just going to be like you're starting
that fight all over again
and
a hint that maybe durability is uh is
less our items are gonna break more
frequently your weapons specifically
yeah looking at here's path mode again
this will let you sort of see where
you've been in the game it'll retrace
your steps from your entire playthrough
which for some of us is in triple digits
yeah I guess this will save up to 200
hours of gameplay so I guess we'll be
covered and then getting into lesser
things in specifics the travel medallion
is going to be a new fast travel thing
that'll let you put one place on the map
that you can move and you can travel
there and we got a bunch of armor
starting with the quark mask misko's
treasure I don't know what that is and
perches what does misko's traffic I
think that's basically the compilation
misko will show you where all the pieces
are gotcha
so we're gonna switch now to Wiest
wanted to go through that and switch to
my safe right it's so cool we can just
swap in our switches give me that and
switch them we can switch them cool
I suppose give it a second here and warm
it up yeah you guys are probably
wondering hey whatever happened to Dino
DNA maybe some of you are wondering
whatever happened to Dino DNA I think
Rob and I are retiring my life as
dinosaur hunters yeah but but depending
I have the stream goes we're thinking
about maybe you know reviving Triforce
heroes I think so and master mode and
playing the entirety of the game on
master mode I think that's plan because
that seems like a hell of a journey
I know everything we were looking for
when we used to do Triforce was all
about okay let's pick a challenge you
know cuz they get me we've pretty much
figured out the game at that point
yeah but master mode apparently makes
everything very very challenging so yeah
alright so heading towards the the
trials right now what are you getting
into it you have to prepare anything I
mean you basically start from scratch
right so when you do start you get that
like you know that intro to the shrine
we're too cold and it says like go to
the Deku forest hint hint nudge nudge
and then these just pop right into your
side quests so these are you know as you
can see there they're hints at these new
art pieces so we're gonna start doing
these straight-up trial two sword we'll
do later strange mask someone do that
let's do it all right let's see what we
go now oh and here's all obviously
hero's pass pass excuse me
so look at you look look where I've been
I mean the best part about this feature
is just getting a chance to see where
you literally have not been in the game
which is kind of crazy to think about
like I mean you look at some of these
landmarks and you're like why haven't I
scaled that mountain before Yeah right
and it's definitely like this isn't just
like paths that are laid out in the game
right I mean this is where you walked
right yeah if you like play you can see
I think it's playing is it where you
died or who died yeah so this is where I
I made a tweet last night was the first
thing I did last night and I was
laughing at this which is a kind of hard
to manage the zooms here but where are
you
that's tough it there you go so I play
it I just play oh here we go it is play
okay sorry guys here we go nope nope
play
yeah I'm just trying to get to the even
side here it's really funny anyways
play dude I'm not used to these at all
okay so based on the timeline right it's
good this should incorporate 200 hours
so you've played what 190 hours at this
point I I've played 300 in over 350
hours what yeah I just did all the
shrines new clothes all right let's get
out here we're stalling huh okay I'm
proud of you or sorry I yeah I I really
like this game Peter yeah I know it's
it's really good I'm super stoked that
we've got a chance to jump back into it
frankly I don't know we have to play a
lot of games for her job and it's easy
to like put one behind you and forget
about it totally and I felt kind of sad
that I had to do that so yeah the plus
is the portability factor like playing
on a couch and like watching mindlessly
like the office have done that plenty of
times it's like cuz I've been love
leveling up my armor which is very like
mine
after grinding you're just doing the
same thing over and over trying to find
freaking like toenails right fire key
swings oh here's a tip I realized so you
know we have these chests to look for so
one thing I would recommend did you take
a picture of a chest one type of chest
apply to all yeah they're all the same
okay so then you go to dang it I'm so
bad at this right now it's been a while
okay yeah you go over here so you can
select treasure and target so now look
show me when there's one nearby but
we're actually going see you I think
we're talking to someone morning so yeah
we - you don't you should turn on your
magnetic thing I'm willing to bet it's
in the water right nearby yeah see in
the middle of Lake there's always a
chest in the lake bro get up
so this is the strange mask quest we
might find a little of the water and
that which can I believe it like just
like the monster masks yeah it's
actually fine Alec I think all lower
level enemies will like not help like
attack you opposed to just like a
specific one we're out sorry
so elegant this is switch gameplay Jimmy
Simmons
actually probably on this offer I feel
like I like briefly kind of started one
the other day and it was like you read a
book and it kind of showed all these
things are how post Midas is inside it's
probably guy at the table too great
that wouldn't be hand
no not that's the counter talking about
over here oh oh but no but look at okay
yeah cool it's not Tracy Oh
so what is the the quark mask is
supposed to just shake when your New
York or XC basically yeah okay dragon
taco this DLC doesn't really feature too
much story essentially what it does is
adds new items to the game and puts
those behind very simple quests but it
chiefly gives you a new difficulty mode
that you have to play from the beginning
of the game but then it also adds the
trials of the sword which lets you power
up the master sword to its highest level
right so currently release at 30 all
right so it said pretty much what does
that shield you've got on your back
Oh Lionel [ __ ] okay I'm sure we'll see
some of those guys beat those guys with
ease stasis helps all right
hidden in the hollow the tariff entry
and the force that causes those who
entered who's there way find that force
just in the lost woods this is one that
Justin was saying is the most annoying
one
well let's knock it out first then yeah
man is that it though like alright yeah
so but but once we're there you can just
turn on your alarm
you know the sensor mm-hmm and use
magnesium point where should we wing it
I would go because it's in here right so
probably the tower just southeast of it
start getting yes sir cool
yeah for those of you who like no or
these uh are we kind of wanted to go in
blind for the surprise factor the trials
are really fun yeah again I did floors 1
to 14 which is like that first phase so
I level up from 30 to 40 on my master
sword and we're gonna replay it again
but there's all these little like tricks
and and you know utilizing your
environment
of course you have to with no armor or
any of your like recipes or anything
like that okay so where's that damn hose
over here so I thought you've done all
the shrines I have done all the friends
so how come you don't have all the hurts
that's a good question because I I hit
my last shrine I was like uh what's up
with this apparently that's just it you
can't either you max out all your hearts
or you max out your stamina oh okay yeah
and I chose stamina because I think it's
just way more necessary climbing and
scaling Jim Simmons you are correct the
switch does use sort of a modified
version of the nvidia tegra check I saw
when I first hit this oh yeah I remember
coming to the office and telling me like
do you remember like we were I was
trying to describe it to you being Vegas
tough but yeah like one of those really
magical moments this game totally yeah
and figuring this out with the fire got
it just like felt like I was playing
crane again that's possible with my
nephews playing that right now and he's
like sending me emails like asking for
help and it's like it's so tough to just
not telling me it's right
you make up your own little riddle can
you were a bad good call
all righty
yeah this sensor was really helpful
again with the trials too because there
are kind of hidden chests think it's off
to your right that's the same so say the
sensor the thing is I can't go off the
path else I wore back out right there's
two there's two tells as far as like
where the path is I know it's like the
direction of the wind and then the fire
which you could manage that zoom with
your sight that over there oh yeah I
mean if you have to go that way because
of the flame I mean yeah okay so it's
probably inside that tree into you know
a tree like that no that oh it's hollow
but there's a lot of those all right
like pretty much every big tree that
looks like it's one of those twisted
yeah yeah this seems wrist gay what's
worse that happened will get sent back
like I'll die in real life oh I should
use this too if it is magnetic I wonder
if some of these trees you actually have
to climb into them from the good just be
right in there yep bingo was his name-o
awesome e X that was epic it's pretty
dope let's try this on uh-huh mm-hmm yep
mm-hmm
yep mm-hmm that's how you win hey what's
up you guys have are you the legendary
hero
you guys have public bathrooms all right
next on the list
[Laughter]
hey guy use your bathroom can I get a
cup of water what are the fairy clothes
Oh tingle tingle let's do that because
that's a probably a three-piece and what
if it's like outpost rules okay yeah I
remember this so this is where I had
just gone to this location and I stopped
playing because I was focused on the
trials yeah upside down but then it
would be a heart right we don't want
that I don't want that torch would make
it slightly easier says Erik I I talking
about the direction of the flames up
it's Carrie I stopped using torches you
know fire weapons man hardcore fire
weapons it's all you need thank you guys
for joining us this is not quite
Triforce but it is Peter and Rob when we
are playing Rob is gone that's correct
actually I don't think I need this time
because this thing is freaking annoying
yeah yeah like I really like an
alternate sound you know alternate sound
or just no sound I mean there's an icon
sure it flashes sure
oh [ __ ] Lionel that's only an answer
holy [ __ ] you have not maxed out all the
quark seeds I'm guessing
have you no I think I have like 130 of
900 our I think Justin - Justin get him
or is he getting him on Oh one more baby
yeah you know what I'd love to do is
play the ego plant boss again that was
fun fun that was so great Bert just give
him some of this oh yeah well bud guy
yeah come on guy hit him off the ledge
with good I want to freeze it ask me
that ass
I didn't see one I caught it anyways
banana
it's got to be onon sidetracked as
always where are you maybe if you
weren't so hardcore and turned on your
mini-map
once you go mini-map you never go back
man
looks so much better what has happened
here I think just went to sleep wake up
a second what's your favorite armor I'm
a big fan of the the Guardian armor but
then I will wear the ninja mask mm-hmm
the head because despite our little hat
upset I don't actually like the Guardian
half that much no no I'm not a big fan
of the Guardian that either it's so
ridiculous
like it's a battle it's a battle suit
like how is that what about you me me Oh
little old me I just go classic you want
to know how much I like the Hylian gear
is how much as I leveled up one that's
white so when I'm snowboarding I look
sick how much of a loser is that I'm a
loser
it's okay thanks all right
I think we're close
these are ruins all right you don't
think I went to this last night does
your map show that it's right no you're
way off damn it
[Music]
no I'll just be better at this okay I
got sidetracked okay
upgrade the soldier set the soldier set
reminds me of when Sam and Frodo war or
gear like it doesn't look like it fits
in my opinion no no you're right
it's like just too wide and bulky in the
wrong places yeah damned bingo okay all
right I hid them so I could write in
this journal so you could find him okay
yeah this is okay so an ancient mask
lies in the ruins where soldiers
gathered so I'm assuming the Colosseum
probably yeah if lick Cola MO is nearby
yeah yeah green garments of the man who
wished to be a fairy are hidden in the
ruins I will field that's a little a
little more ambiguous find these place
pieces at the ruins where a trade
flourished well they're risen yeah oh so
these are three different lunch these
are three different locations then right
that sounded like more
yeah they're laying out a bunch of stuff
here
dang temple ruins soaked in the waters I
even know where that rumor is okay what
the hell it's the kids telling you about
everything yeah it's it just it's going
through all of them that's weird okay
okay could it mean
this is previous page I just do that
yeah I did okay so where did we go then
let's look at this again hidden the
ruins of hyrule field trip or trade
flourished at the ruins were sinners are
in prison right okay trade flourished so
yeah go to Hyrule Field exchange ruins
damn that was easy like that's got yet
yeah go cook cool if you guys got any
questions in the chat we'll do our best
to answer them are you guys still
playing this game yeah I've got what I
want to know I don't know tell me what's
your game like what's your game like I
yeah the master mode man we were talking
about it like I don't I was conflicted
with starting a whole new game but as we
were talking this morning it seemed
seemed like the perfect thing to stream
again especially if it really does
fundamentally change like everything
about the game in terms of how capable
you are in the face of danger like
that's that's this whole game right yeah
is overcoming obstacles yeah
yeah like we were talking about how
eventually we you know when you get
pretty overpowered like you're not
inclined to use stealth as much there's
no reason like with this like the
Majora's Mask which is again supposed to
disguise you from enemies like your your
you really want that mask if you are
just trying to get from A to B and and
not interact with any book oblem camps
which now have like more enemies and
they're higher level yeah and they see
you at twice the distance or something
like that like geez should turn the
sensor on good call where you were
headed already this isn't it though I
don't think that's not okay
cuz I do know that enemies are NPCs
react to you wearing tingle yeah yeah I
saw that you and I won the same boy Papa
look into my weird eyes there was a
treasure chest buried in a ground that
might be oh damn good on that is it look
at that all right next up huh yes we
need to go to ruins or sinners
imprisoned prison we're going to prison
let's go to jail
all right it's got to be close to the
castle
I mean the prison the the prison proper
is inside the castle but I have inside
they kind of like alluded to all of
Hyrule Field hit that record button oh
well okay I do feel like I've I've come
across like a ruin at prison but I feel
like the nîmes right away garrison hmm
caris oh well that would be where
soldiers gather and isn't that one of
the things yeah you're right you talked
to two of those yeah
yeah so I'd go there okay you could just
book it there sure hello swell
was it nighttime yeah
let's speed this up Jim Simmons again
asking about how this looks compared to
the the Wii U version now and
you know what there's not a huge
difference it's kind of marginal but I
do know that playing to switch one of
them testing out the way you want it did
feel just just enough less that I was
happy to be playing this wish mm-hmm
yeah
come to me my jungle I need to go back
to Hyrule Castle and get some that Royal
Guard gear was good there you go except
for the accordion someone thinks they're
gonna take my hello we're flying through
this wrecked Oh phantom tights I was not
expecting that I was hoping that phantom
was going to be
was gonna be in the Coliseum what was
that feels like a staff with like a blue
that's the Royal or just sorry ancient
spear Age
yeah oh it must be the color temperature
this monitor or something cuz that's
right this guy volume for volleys galas
maybe use really didn't need to put any
of that armor on but you look hot I
think so oh you're making his day Jesus
he's like legendary hero yeah come on
horrible was a red one too alright
what's next the prison again
[Music]
in and I want to look this up no no
sorry what is this post ruins Oh what
the hell God posts
oh we were here yeah that well that's
where we got the a the quest rather
alright so what should I look for here
tingle outfit namely well hell unless
you guys know in the chat the right
we're so owners yeah I mean you you got
to go to the prison inside the in hyrule
castle town prison yeah so to the west
of the hyrule castle moat there's a
small island with the road curving
through it
oh here yeah so it's the side of the
road closest to the castle are the ruins
of the prison so the chest the chest is
buried in the ground so audio died the
audio has died back tight Rob can you
read Don Ho be skis question sure that's
I'm odorous damned gay sir biggest penis
bigger in interest interesante its what
about armor
yeah the armor is where interesting I
don't I'm sorry
can anyone translate that question
what do you see
describe it to me strategy I see
guardians that bud what a lonely lonely
Caracas okay
Oh check this out right this last time
to me the only power I use it's
addicting yeah I think if I arguably the
least likable champion how do you feel
about if we go through masternode again
for try for us that we that we make fast
travel not an option
Oh God awesome rocker was doing some
like that right this is Austin Walker I
believe was playing the game oh yeah
only three deaths and no fast travel
something wonder if he even got that far
well the fast travel that just is a time
thing that's not although I could see
getting stuck in a difficult spot like
this guy okay okay okay okay okay
move leg number three then no no no okay
this is not God's creaming on the inside
all right man what if the Guardians are
piloted by turncoat Horrocks I love that
thank you for the translation
Andre Oh someone also asked what was
that question Oh how do you dye your
armor it's good question you do it in
Altona
potato town and you need to bring Jesus
you'd have basically items or
ingredients that resemble the color you
want right so if you want it black you
gotta have like you know six items that
are black right red not purple but black
some of our real tough like I know like
navy or dark blue is like sapphire is
like one of the only ones I know of yeah
obviously expensive yeah
geez where's this thing gamerpoop you
can't see the abilities on the left side
because we've got the sort of minimal
hood the pro hood I believe it's called
turndown I like it but I if you really
want me to turn on on or off I can do
that no where is this specify where show
me on your map right now where you at it
was behind us oh no no I
oh no that's oh you're right also what
the hell what the hell now this is
probably because you haven't been there
I guess that's weird do your job
Oh turn on hero's path I guess I found
out yeah what is your can you get like
from a really high vantage point you
just get really high and then look for
it sure that's good
I know a curl core off you Scott's great
stuff you guys looking for some seeds
[Music]
underground okay follow the sensor here
that stops right here you know these
walls look like they can blow up no what
did it exactly say or in the Y so to the
west of Hyrule Castle monk there's a
small island with a curved road on the
side of the road closest to the castle
are the ruins of the prison the chess
tis buried in the ground here bingo
bango bango bolongo okey-dokey
artichokey
holy moly where's the goalie dang that's
a good one dingo put that in my pocket
get food Kapoor these are my pants can
you take his pants off yeah normal child
he's got cool little watch bling-bling
what time is it ask the boy single time
- ting go home if you think you think
the clock actually reflects the real
time yeah what time does that look like
check your eyes like four nope
[Laughter]
all right next on the list here we go
[Music]
the ruins were sinners yeah villager so
here's the thing actually we
accidentally did one of these right yeah
so thus it's cool we were looking for we
need to go to the village ruins next to
the farmland where many people once
gathered okay dope so castle square is
where they would have gathered and the
farm to the east well you know just grow
these
I wonder if this is another case where I
don't have it maybe but I think you're I
think you're veering way too far come on
it's okay I think cuz people would
typically gather ranch Hyrule Castle
town right I mean that's the that's the
town okay a central square so if you
look around this area you will find like
a yeast building yes I'm saying maybe
even further north you keep going south
I can I might not be up there anything
look like a farm here
what would you go out here and just get
a little vantage point in action and
Charlie's nearby Charles mm-hmm Oh
charlie horse yeah I have another good
name what I call I the Ganon's horse I
called it something really cool Lon Lon
ranch ruins was being calm I called I
call maurices I think I call him that
Reese's Pieces black and orange farm on
a prairie yeah you ever seen that
remember that show Little House on the
Prairie vaguely wasn't it wasn't a huge
fan he was a boring ass whip him out all
the time and I was like poor give up
dude while earning this talking [ __ ]
he's my boy Charlie boy I love how you
could do this just like with a metal
gear you know you could feed a horse
injera carrot and get extra to do that
you can feed your horse about hobbling
guts and feel awesome for being such a
sicko it's not cool
oh really can you do that yeah doc I
don't know what's up with this guy we're
gonna have a steady diet of guts and
Tony dude I love how you ride backwards
like this it's so badass
okay all right
hmm I mean maybe slap on that treasure
chest to censor or you've got it on you
can't do it Bob Jones is pissed off that
you didn't use a shock arrow on those
bats I thought about it
dang well I'll do right now look for you
Bob nice another all right
what do we see what we see describe it
to me I see a castle see
well there's a supply hmm Oh sweets go
straight check this thing out maybe
prairies maybe maybe I wonder if that's
after Ravalli scale is now ready what
was what was the I came a long long
ranch made anything up wasn't it the
girl in that the redhead was her name in
Ocarina I was like Jennifer Jennifer
don't call her Jin
Jenny is cool down she's talented
all right I don't know oh my tingle
senses yeah I mean I don't know on long
ranch yeah yeah I think moose torture
was right
No what's up horse [ __ ]
Oh tickle its belly
oh [ __ ] dude it's kind of rocking me
oh I got you to eat something else
toenails you know apparently you can't
level up the all this armor which is a
bummer
yeah you mean like some of it can be
leveled up I don't think any of it I
mean I buy it I don't like it
he's fluttery rush choo-choo
[Music]
[Music]
getrekt gosh alright yep Oh use the
pulse Robert I am barefoot it's probably
I took so much damage anything anything
up watch it he's eager oh we think this
looks pretty good I thought that was
chest well there's probably gonna be
just a regular old one around here all
right well that's right you know you can
flip be using like that parts yeah all
right tingle Knight speed up like his
little cone head shakes
Garriott gear so that's it it just does
uh yeah you got it no but like I'd
rather wear Dark Link at night than this
does that also have night speed or just
innate strength or whatever just the
same deal yeah you can't little that one
up here alright next up I guess Oh
Majora's and then the rest of this
mm-hmm you're here that's the one I
really want
phantom okay go to the ferry and seating
upgrades pretty sure it doesn't scare
everybody says ETA
yes garrison people hmm
I'm scared yeah um okay what have we
done
fun puzzle fantastique so a graveyard
yeah yes and wait I think we did the
ruins where shoulders are gathered right
I'm pretty sure about that's one we did
yes yes yes oh so brave I yeah yeah
so the battlegrounds were brave souls
tested their skill is the Colosseum yeah
it still is huh yeah okay should we do
that or yeah well let's do what's the
other one we maybe we're near by will
see it on we haven't done the graveyard
yes
presumably okay although it might be the
sacred grounds where they're honored
yeah I like like that yeah closest [ __ ]
[Music]
conveniently
I'm gonna wreck your face get brick
[Music]
oh man dude Guardians would see you
closer in master mode
they've already been so many instances
well I feel like I'm in a whole
different part of the map like on top of
a mountain I'm in here yeah they're
ridiculous
oh man these guys are close they know
what I want
Oh
hey what you doing there get on my hey
SNSD let's let's give them the real
thing
dang it Oh double get lit with the hell
thanks man
get your ass back
[Music]
and going through a lot of arrows
engineer as it is those are not cheap
what tase calling you out for not
fighting them like a badass to their
shield alright dude they're firing -
well I just want to show like you that's
like not the timing
yeah you like that tape do it do it come
on come on all right
don't get cocky kid watch it come on do
it
what Bob Joan says you need a lot of
practice yeah not this back are you more
so than most people who play this game
got him I don't do it that often it can
live in The Guardian arrow life and that
is how you take down a cartoon all right
anyways we are feet away from a chest
[Laughter]
friends - Charlie's just making out with
that tree over cool that's a bummer if
you can't level that thing up let's go
play football my pads I love it rising
something okay cause you okay I know I
want that phantom armor - I don't think
I do looks crazy
yeah Nick dog what's that mean
eggnog oh yeah I think so
do you like eggnog uh-huh complicated
answer yeah I like the flavor of eggnog
and I like to drink it but if I ever
drink like a full glass of it I'm going
to the Coliseum fight me am I not a
warrior
oh oh you want to go oh we're doing some
selfies later screw that we're going
right now
oh what's that you say damn what's that
take that shot what are you doing
this world needs a hero
I'm not hero also I what I must my
shadow
don't let them know I'm constipated it's
on the toilet is mine party
and what people will say when I have Oso
tingle is the one that hi tingle is the
one that has funny bothers everybody
they all just they they get real like a
shock like you'd be carrying a bomb
what hey see kids around here okay bye
this better be in the it's better be in
the Coliseum not like outside of it in
fact this amazing fit I'm not gonna lie
this armor gives me gas major gas his
body is so big so big oh you know what
kind of rise me up is you see um what
was that recent stop animation movie it
was really pretty good actually yeah the
the roach character who played by I
think in the kana hang kinda reminds me
of that he's just like all chest all
right we got here what's our situation
boys I'm home
I'm here for the chest gah you scum I
[Music]
mean it's gotta be on the yeah I'd be
surprised if it was too far like they
want you to fight this silver I call
that a sword slap hmm it was nothing
that's my patrol got this area covered
Fred let's rock this guy get rockin baby
I am ready to go oh yeah this is
Twilight but I got an amoeba I took
[ __ ] forever excuse my language
yeah did you like that
can't you just hit him with it's nice
nice cool it's not very cross
[Music]
yes I wanted to stop I'm gonna tear you
down
let's do it no dang it Oh screw this
you're not going to say mark dang it
he's gonna take a while to speed this
your weapon now you can use that one
from distance too so you don't have to
although you do want to watch Clarion
[Music]
okay
maybe this was a bad idea I'm training
for trials
nope sorry often I lost my line of oh
dang
good good
good job Rob chat must have loved that I
want to earn it
want to earn this thing I'm definitely
ditching something good the line I'll
[ __ ] on the ground looks different than
the one my love yeah it does actually
okay awesome Savage you drop the slab of
Jordan your victims too regular no I
think both of them are Savage whoa sick
now I can hide my face so heavy in the
middle it's his legs and his arms they
just don't hello
all right is this where are the evil
Knights gather no good I'm here I'm home
all right last one right for this class
no we're done with this we're done yeah
we just need to get the a what's a
called oh oh and if we want to get the
what he call medallion well that would
be the teleportation rumors right so we
got two x Treasury things lives so we
have Majora's Mask
oh and Midna in Midna okay uh yeah see
this Rob everyone's he picked up the
wrong bow did I
thanks guys appreciate it thank you
all right so okay okay look at the show
that you picked up I'm just curious what
is the difference so it's worse it looks
yeah weird it looked different on the
ground there didn't it oh it was
probably face like oh yeah you're right
that's it that's it all right
I believe South Paulo is up here bingo
WeChat sorry we are getting close once
we do these we'll get to the point where
we are gonna do the trials of the sword
so yeah yeah yeah yes I mean that's a
bummer if like that phantom armor it was
like level 8 and you can't upgrade it
like yeah why do we think that we can't
upgrade it is that like confirmed well I
saw on reddit but this is not
necessarily confirmed I think people
were saying that do you just need to
find is there maybe like a new fairy
phone now they they all operate the same
as far as I know like
that's only some of them I thought they
dealt with like specific types of armor
like you'd have to go to one no no like
I level I just kept going to what's it
calls the one near Tarrytown oh oh he's
scared of me too mm-hmm what does it to
say what talking it's fake shut up go
away
you so much let's read it
Tracy here
hmm
okay let's not do that one is that
that's where we have to go to those big
mazes and work our way down to like the
certain point that takes it to the
basement that's gonna take way too long
damn really yeah all right oh I know
which one it would be it's like this one
yeah you know what I mean you have to
somehow get to the entrance that lets
you get to the bottom you know you can
get there through the shrine oh you can
yeah I'm I'm like I'm really sure I'm
pretty sure like the the shrine is like
the whole point of getting through the
maze is you know obviously ending at
shrine oh right and you can just drop
down that's true I'm pretty sure no does
sound right oh but there's one thing
just one more thing there's a ton of
Guardians in there yeah but that's cool
that's fine I'll come quickly with my
arrows I will not be using the shield
though yeah
oh yeah good guy maybe Guardian armor
[Music]
how can you shoot mr. question
[Music]
all right oh if we had pretty
why would how this works
yeah so while it won't happen it's
they're cool yes better fit all tight
all right well uh next on the list its
majora's mask or Minnes stupid roars
last yeah so Midna would be the Twilight
relic mm-hmm so her helmet can be found
at the temple ruins soaked in the waters
of the ridge NC a river I think I
remember there being ruins those ruins
everywhere I guess
so we're River
here we go yeah yep right here I'm
assuming right here those of your owns
yeah all right thank you guys for
sticking with us yeah we will be getting
to the trials of these sword very soon
so we take a look at the master mode
after we get these two well real real
quick just to see it just as soon as
like yeah all right he's got a text from
Zelda yeah she says how's the shopping
going link she says yeah you suck you
suck at this [ __ ] damn link what are you
doing hey babe drying on these new pants
I'm dying
what do you think of my hat really
tingle I know taking selfies what do you
think how did the house look there were
these pants look I should do a tingle at
night since I do run faster at night so
much fast to get that I guess if you
don't need to upgrade anything you
probably don't I have five or six
oh how many pieces money bags over here
where's the tingle chest peace in our
hearts hearts I can't remember where it
was you're wearing it
oh you mean like wearing them someone in
oh yeah some 100 shot was a yeah we
forgot but yeah you can google this
stuff is all over the Internet all right
so just log on to the World Wide Web or
HTTP colon slash slash
gwg le calm or Peter or you can hang
tight for an hour guy coming towards the
other day yeah actually this talk is not
on the internet yet GameSpot will have
the first scoop of all this info all
right back to business
I only I've ever been here before Jesus
its girl a alright my under it
crazy yeah I think this is it yeah
definitely treasure yeah look at Miss
moneybags
well we better try this thing on get it
on all right
I love that hair sweet what does it do I
don't know garden resist okay
bye like how much yeah really
well apparently does something with Wolf
amiibo I think but I don't know what
that's been rumor yeah yeah if it's
something cool and maybe someone else I
can run in with a wolf amiibo what's
next our last one here
all right try it with the Guardian armor
oh thanks for watching video mode five
to nine
your presence is much appreciated well I
don't know if it gives me that set bonus
but no but no it looks stupid
what what's worse this I know right for
this look this is worse
yeah I think I'm a crazy I don't know
it's all weird don't know oh right
oh did we not actually get there no we
we were suspecting this was the garrison
uh oh I thought Colosseum as well but
where's like oh it's not right here I
think well I don't know man huh why do
you think is the garrison isn't that
where soldiers hang out like in real
life
yeah I guess you're right did it say
like what direction
no but it said that you can see yeah
you're right you're right you're right
mmm that's real close I think there's a
bunch of guard enjoying this tower
best dead air ever mm all right so yeah
we are gonna collect the final piece of
the the new armor the new DLC stuff for
breath of the wild and I'm gonna jump
into the did you want to do master mode
or the trance I kind of want to see
master hook just for a second cool we
would not spend much time on that over
here yeah
[Music]
Master mode is the new like super hard
difficulty you have to start the game
all over enemies are tougher smarter and
faster all that trials are a series of
little mini challenges that you have to
complete and once you do the Master
Sword will be leveled up to aspires rank
cool I want anyway how's that chest
gonna throw anyone in here dang it super
Dalyan
come here is tap Rose that when you were
facing that way yeah I don't have that
Jarek to see me
this tower seems interesting yeah do you
think about this oh yeah
nope no but you can probably get a good
read on I think we checked here we did
okay yeah thinking all right over here
with that little farm maybe
can we ever go to that section that you
were talking about that might be a great
as far as the mouth goes we were looking
at
I mean this seems like I should be it
and I'm like inclined to kind of incline
just to open these up drop my weapon or
lay down so I can narrow it down
you know gasps all right let's drop it
poke mmm oh yeah sure I don't eat this
[Music]
sick
he's just not here where else could
there be
this is her majoras right yeah I'd be
gatepost no what was it again um the
great plateau tower yeah destination is
the southernmost part of the outpost
ruins would you what you have there
I'm trying to fill in so this is the
south shore of Lake Como you'll find the
Colombo garrison ruins northwest through
the forest of time from your location at
the outpost ruins yeah I mean it wait
till it's outpost ruins okay wait
no there's two if you go you see a
little thing that's jutting into the
lake they load massive land yeah that's
another garrison okay so we weren't too
far off let's fly remember that guy who
used bomb arrows and God fly from yeah
from the north to the south yeah of the
whole map just shooting the ground and
lighting fires isn't the same
[Music]
hey fellas yeah I got this yeah I've
definitely never been there before god
that's insane to think what else am I
missing in this game like have you been
here before I don't know it's kind of
crazy honestly I need to put up my
scripts and take a look at the girls
back there still I there are so many
shrines and core oxys I have not found
all right last up
[Music]
with our situation to the ground yeah
yeah really you can just throw those
jellies on there right yeah good I'm
surprised though it's damn [ __ ] nobody
likes me I was a treasure she blows
gotcha
all right we've done it brother you've
done it apparently this looks really
cool at night yeah damn that was real
cool right now Wow stare into my soul do
you have any so where's your restroom
dude I am not letting in my bathroom
come on just number one real quick I'll
even sit down no splashing already there
you're out of toilet paper
like we're just talking like Jiminy
Glick looks [ __ ] cool oh yeah these
guys won't do anything it does look cool
this is probably one of what's up guys
friend friend yes right now that's funny
[Music]
can't you Styles on the flip later dudes
I've got my eye on you
dang this thing is freaky looking so is
it just the enemies at night that don't
react to you looks well so technically
you can lead enemies into other groups
of enemies and have them fight right cuz
they're following you right now what
enemies fight each other you've never
seen enemies fight in this game no
Guardians you can like have a guardian
fight really yeah yeah yeah this doesn't
say what it really does okay
this thing is cool
alright well should we move right along
now I think we should yeah you should
probably by the way okay that camera
bidness and let's get down to the master
mode let's take a look at it get our ass
kicked
yeah I have even like seen the title
screen as far as like where you change
it cuz apparently all the loading
screens are different too
just real neat it's not that neat they
just turn orange or something today in
master mode turn on yes I would like to
play so the favorite bit of armor you
got today mmm
describe it to me
you know I I didn't think I would like
oh [ __ ] it's a whole new game I don't
think I would like it as much the
majora's mask is freaking cool-looking
man yep that's the correct answer ding
ding being robbed you've won
today's quiz round that is the best
piece of armour yeah I think wake up and
wake up shits about to get real it's
9:00 a.m. you're supposed to be at work
wake get out of bed your breakfast is
cold now I'm throwing it away
link this ain't fair it was really cool
he reminds me of that time that I was
born oh oh dang really you don't
remember when you were born yeah it's a
lot like that smelled funny though it
smelled funny that's the smell of life
my friend
wake up link yeah what is this goo you
know this is gurus just water probably
water let's talk about it
what do you think I think it's jello
which is kind of a goo jello
maybe it's um it's like the stuff in the
matrix yes
KY jelly
it'd be funny if things start throwing
up all this yesterday pull that like
attract thousands of links entombed
around him think guardians just sorry he
goes like get up and all his fingernails
break off I think that's totally normal
so Robert Thomas and Quinn nine seven
seven are saying the Majora's Mask
basically will prevent any enemy except
for Lionel's so yeah so it's really like
it's like the universal monster mask
except for Lionel's sepra Lionel's which
is the same for the Lyle mask like
finals will like look at you weird they
go uh uh I ain't done I am NOT dumb all
right let's get this guy's get this give
it give it thanks can I skip can I skip
it can't escape it can't escape it I
think I'm just doing a version of the
Ross Perot impression from SNL circa
like 1990 can I finish
alright yeah he'd asked to finish it
anybody okay okay well I'm done well we
better put on this old shirt to protect
us from the book Hoffman's because it'll
definitely help and make a difference
difference whoa oh man first thing I
thought I had no hearts so bazi show you
the way video says video code Oh who's
that name video mode dude I know glasses
holy God that's bat bat he says uh wish
there's some story deal see that's
coming
probably expect I'm the end of the year
right fall they've said holiday 2016
okay I have a I have a feeling it's
gonna come like super late probably mid
December
I'm cool with that that could be a nice
you know Merry Christmas Merry Christmas
good winter break get cozy you are the
light our light that must shine upon
Hyrule once again now go now I'm gonna
go back you know that nap I was taking
that was pretty good
we just dial that for another like 200
years oh god oh god already boned
[Music]
that'd be great they changed it where
this starts up Cebu cop who comes just
smacks master mode multiple yeah
you know what I kind of want to do not
really well I'll talk about it so one of
the new things you can do in a latest
switch system update is play in black
and white really yeah dang that could be
real neat you can basically alter how
you can alter how color is represented
for people who have like vision
sensitivities and stuff like that mm-hmm
and I think black and white damn oh we
already get joysticks man you'd eat them
mushrooms shrooming oh god no paraglider
oh god this feels weird
Oh God I heard he just turns into gaming
or he gives you like a cyanide pill he's
like dude it's not worth it
like take it from me man hey man Master
mode I need that you're so screwed let
me pull your leg you like tickling I do
over here good you know they say
wrastlin is the best kind of training do
you know what that Guardian armor kind
of makes it dude that's his armor man
that Guardian excuse me phantom armor
he's got I bet he I bet he once fit into
it look at that it's so in torque yeah
I'm taking all your stuff dude as a
weapon fire
[Laughter]
all right get yourself an axe my you can
have my alright it's about time for me
to watch that movie again yeah that I
did recently after that trailer I might
watch it in like Spanish or something so
it feels like I'm seeing it all over
again for the first time okay dude
alright oh yeah I got rekted oh yeah
Oh recharge oh god oh man he's flapping
them gums he didn't hate - laughing
before
Oh God oh my god
[Music]
is it a bad place to have a fight dude
with no runes - I think we were talking
about before the stream is that you kind
of have to play with a brand new level
of awareness and not engage in combat
just because it's there yeah what calm
menacing this screen is this is dude
this is Halloween every day of your life
so wait I get free candy from strangers
no it's it's it's the bad prankers on
Halloween who give you toilet paper
told no like bad licorice like boiling
water and heated pennies here reach it
in this bowl of boiling water to get
your he's a nice kid yeah you like that
were there gluten-free yeah does that
hurt cuz it's water and boiling water my
hat screw you uh-huh alright let's try
more time and then move on it'd be cool
to kill one guy yeah but I think
honestly to like this is gonna be very
important that you take advantage of the
timing and stuff yeah get ready
yeah uh-huh yep mustard on it
Oh your health don't let no come with
that though is like oh I didn't have
enough time I'm with that though is like
it's like you throw them away you know
you can knock them away or down a hill
meaning is do it even now I'm waiting
for I we're done the strategy before we
commit to a whole yeah we should play a
little bit more I mean God though like
you I want God armor not a stick
oh no that's gonna be fun
yeah sure it'll be fun it'll be fun
Louie fine do a peaceful run of breath
of the wild
that sounds real tough alright Peter
let's get to the meat of it just do the
let's do the trials let me get your
attention real quick to tell you that I
think already capture device has full up
that's fine
I already have the first levels captured
so yeah that's the so that's the real
point is yeah someone has still I mean
obviously have to start a new game so
imagine when eventually someone was
gonna is gonna do those trials in master
mode holy yeah I there's already been a
lot of impressive like feats in terms of
skill that we've seen from the main game
like I kind of can't wait to see what
people managed to do here like the
really high levels players mm-hmm
alright God or speedruns of that stuff
yeah okay well I would say I bet
someone's actually doing that right now
right like a speedrun so master mode
someone's trying to really wherever the
first person is to beat it will have
done the speedrun
I'm curious Ganon right now I'm curious
like how is how are those fights going
to evolve right I mean yeah you consider
just walking through that that castle
right
I mean yet alone like the actual fights
fighting for of those flights yeah and
then Ganon oh if you were to do that
yeah if you were to skip the we call it
the dungeons I guess for lack of a
better word no you're right though cuz
like if if the durability thing is real
then then I would you know maybe it will
have to take longer right you got to
find more weapons and stuff right all
right dude oh I'm nervous I'm really
[ __ ] oh this is gonna look cool no
it's cool now this is look cool for the
cinematic it's gonna cool
woah link
oh yeah he's pretty awesome you feel
like this could have been included into
the main game really all this stuff
could have been cuz I got I can tell you
like once I got the Master Sword I kind
of felt like oh that's all it took mmm I
agree yeah just getting hearts that's a
good point
what if it was like actually getting the
sword yeah I mean cuz getting it is one
step right getting it to its maximum is
the next one I think that could have
played out you know cuz then there's so
much talk of the sword and all totally
off like from everyone in the game
totally unless my eyes deceive me you
look insane
look into my eyes
the majora's mask have those breathing
holes it looks like don't think so keep
yawning it's all good any more coffee
yeah yes let's do this
oh no forgot to do something what to
cook to eat yeah it's alright okay
so yeah I have not mentioned this the
whole time so a good tip for doing
trials is you can as you know your armor
and everything you have is gone but you
can eat buffs and stasis stuff or
statuses excuse me and those carry on
into here so I made like three times
attack 30 minutes as far as like meals
yeah and defense so you can yeah I think
it's him but then once you're in here no
and look at my health too [ __ ] totally
forgot what to do this is being the
first trial he's using to kill the
enemies that's it and then it'll sort of
open up a portal to the next correct
section
[Music]
so yeah and other tips would be you know
look around there are bird eggs in the
trees there are sometimes chests that's
another thing and all this stuff
obviously you have to look forward to
the next stage of right now so right
weird to like have these supplies as
they get more difficult right pocket
that meat check out from their suits
take off see weapons so yeah I also have
that treasure chest turned on still just
helpful apparently also is like if you
you know you can take using the sensor
you can take a picture of like an enemy
you can take it like a photo of like a
phoenix right and if I were to turn that
on it'll let me know if he's in the next
for so really yeah apparently I could
try it
do we get he you got one at 1:21 you go
no 1:23 but those are lying on 121 is ya
at the base level well regardless we can
at least see that let's do like uh see
if it works right
I'm mob one yeah see if it works
all right let's not even showing up
though it it only shows up if there is
one to detect it wouldn't it wouldn't go
now is that true also I know the force
cuz I played this verse fourteen of
these so far and I think it's like maybe
level three or four alright I think
that's about it let's let's rock any big
fourth of July plans around no no what
about you I'm doing the most American
thing by going out to have French French
dinner
yes French meals I love it we booked my
girlfriend thinks it's the French
restaurant then I was like hey let's
grill and she was like did you forget no
I can't wait Bram also worth noting is
that like the choo-choos won't drop Chu
Chu jelly likewise no problems won't
drop their monster parts Oh God so
another thing is like there are a couple
times to where like where you really do
want to stealth and isolate certain guys
like I might go for this guy and get his
bow first granted you didn't see me
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ooh I'm wasting arrows Oh actually do
that yeah sexy dude so that was the
thing so fire teachers aren't
necessarily necessarily there just to
like hurt you they're actually there to
help you in teaching element yeah like
so he I could have used his you know the
fire the wind of the what do you call it
the heat from the fire to rise up and
get on this you could also dude let this
guy just fire arrows and yet so it's
fine he said that yeah do that Dave said
that I was like oh my god of course
[Music]
I shot oh but then again I am losing
there's another shield go to your left
[Music]
yeah plus eventually I don't want this
field let's get a couple more ooh
[Music]
honeycomb here no oh but yeah it was
honey for sure I'd be really helpful
yeah I use the honey on some meat yeah
tasty if you ever have you ever made
something this game and then like one
out yeah I did that was sushi I was like
I want sushi now so yeah there should be
some eggs and some of these trees but
I'm not gonna spend forever yeah alright
skip that poem oh alright so here's the
one see those chests and far back there
yeah so you think oh this is easy just
one little lonely ass idiot think again
yeah so you got to use you can just liar
you can just throw stones
honey mean pick them up and throw a
stone at the pickup oh yeah you could
yeah you're right actually I was doing
that last time yeah but yeah so I can't
kill them all I'm gonna miss out on
these fire arrows I believe that next
one is a of course doing this
[Music]
yeah that great though cool if there's
something else now let's get this guy's
[Music]
oops wrong one Oh forgot about that
eat rock what'd you do my brother yeah
so there are a lot of rocks I think
sometimes metal boxes are are meant to
like be dropped on hoses yeah let's work
doesn't that hurt you dude oh come on oh
my god
yeah screw that great
Oh what more remember that oh they get
bigger to just say take more damage from
they're on fire
yeah
[Music]
okay so once you got past the 14th or
15th one you said that you had like a
moment to rest did you get literally I
left okay you leave the trials and then
your yeah your store gets ten plus as
far as level I show you and you'd
ideally you would do that two more times
and get sixty yeah but I would imagine
that it ramps up oh this one was kind of
tricky something you can bomb trees for
acorn oh yeah it's good point it's true
I can't move this is why there's
something up here just a dude no he's
got explosive barrels
[Music]
what what's going on
[Music]
potential
Congress winged it there oh thanks dude
there you go fun ticket say if you don't
have like many inventory slots you
probably want to like spend some time
getting those yeah up there yeah then
obviously your your powers don't work so
I can't use that that Gayo without is
Gail
what is that noise I hear
no one more I think he drops out one
more enemy yeah oh maybe yeah there's
other round top this is what you had
right yeah it was oh sorry bub like
they'll like ring like wrestling ring
ding-ding-ding man that's no match oh
yeah good stuff yeah yeah we got so yeah
floor 7 will be where I take a little
break so really when they say 45 floors
I would imagine like three of those are
breathers
yeah and now it actually makes sense
because the way that they have worded it
it's at about 45 and it was like why
would it be about and not exactly right
there we go
he thinks they're a treasure chest on
this floor so it didn't work I had that
modeling thing on now it works some guy
was saying that like he did it with a he
annex maybe was a bug and the heinous
was very alerted him that there was the
next word do quit ox
there are 45 floors now we are aware of
and we have not seen all of them nothing
rob has played up through 15 at the
moment for 14 14 so we're currently on
number five for mm-hmm like that so
again I'm like you kinda wanna do
stealth like this you know if he real
step like Danny I move rough that would
be a good weapon once you get it oh come
on
[Music]
right in the play yeah that was that was
a good weapon
dang Oh
Doubleday oh that's a club I don't like
that and his buddies are coming out yeah
they would hear that nothing to see here
[Music]
my favorite move yep
let me try that move oh you're a little
late
damn it back yeah you laugh it up
[Applause]
[Music]
don't worry it gets harder floor ten man
for ten oh yeah special about for ten
floor ten let me paint this for you
what's office lizalfos
we all know they suck well there's a
bunch of them
oh my god I was dumb and there's just
like it's like there's an area like east
of Hyrule Castle that's like the
wetlands or there's all those lifts and
like was off those are all in there yeah
so like it's that but it's it's all
water so like you're you're constantly
like falling off and they'll bill cult
bill dive in and like spit oh you're in
the water yeah
no I'm their aim is really good Yeah
right far and they yeah they're kind of
like Lionel's are they like they'll fire
off like three hoses just like dogging
one
let's move along yeah there are 45 fours
oh yeah this is a good one
can you see what's coming on here what's
coming on yeah I see what's gonna come
on Oh folder going dang it dang that's a
good name to stick folder boy come here
that Oh Mondays
I sure hate mondays
[Laughter]
he thinks he's Garfield nope yeah do it
damnit alright I'm doing it yeah I'm
doing real well let's do that this
reason anything better yeah let's start
using these wampum huh yeah we have not
been eating huh
in real life event RL get down thank you
yeah yeah yeah yeah go for the gold
yep
[Music]
not gonna music ends on that that's sick
before we on floor six we are headed
down to floor number seven oh good
basement seven really yeah so I'd like
to imagine also they're like in each of
these you know again I'm speculating I'm
pressuring right three groups of trials
right like there's like you know these
are pre called the beginner trials right
so I really don't know I feel like it's
gonna be a slow descent into hell and
the bottom fifteen are just gonna be
like among fire right I thought they
were like more intensive puzzles and
stuff too right
I don't know but yeah there are two
bosses in this beginner trials every
arrow counts yeah I should've freezed it
more so now you get a chance to cook you
had a chance to catch your breath
exactly
yes you look around you'll see armored
carp here there what's in these oh all
right
take it
yeah bad I just got one of those for the
first time last night
when I was playing mmm BAE full bleed or
they'd like associated with a type of
know like like geardo ever burrito I
think I got it wasn't even from a year
maybe it was just a Chet oh is a chest
the inside of a shrine okay all right
let's go Stu going hell yeah
we're gonna cook up everything so I do
not want to do this all again oh there's
no point having wood oh oh oh no no that
was a fairy oh that was like a second
life dang
damn it forgot that sucks good next time
kid yeah
[Applause]
anything else they go ahead corn Apple
man all right let's cook torch sure so
this is always important right so like
what's you like this will just be good
on its own all right cool so let's
combine some thank you
yeah the stuff you have is only good for
like two ingredients right you don't
have the like like stuff like wheat or
whatever it's like combined for free
yeah that's pretty good
this will probably just do on its own
silence room yeah oh man master mode
this would be very important yeah it's
it it's it's so intimidating but I feel
like I'm for it yeah okay I feel like
the first stretch would be the probably
the hardest right until you like really
ramp up and get actual armor I found out
that
well we'll probably do I don't know what
do you what are you willing to do I mean
if it would say we get past these 14
yeah how do you feel um we can play one
next after that yeah it's to see what
the second bit is like yeah damn I
probably won't get that far that's for
sure it's actually pretty good stuff I
don't remember getting help all right
I I'm gonna eat right now because if I
know it's natural think it's not very
good we go on seven right yeah okay is
probably good I want to use this at the
right time this is a good one I'm gonna
save that I'll use this next it was
lizalfos man
good nice melons okay all right
it's like I'm doing this all in boxer
briefs at some point you gotta get all
right not in not in this one not in the
first 15 yeah or 14 oh yeah that's right
correct
get away from those weapons oh gee can't
dude
horrible crow that's strolling around no
that's not what I wanted to do at all
[Music]
Oh what I've never seen that Mouse
Russia they're learning yeah they are
like Raptors basically yeah what's going
I need to ditch some weapons that's why
I've been like kind of I throw all the
weak ones obviously oh I know there's
one in here
oh yeah isn't y/o and homeboy here
oh god I know right
on the bike nice no he's a little hot
right yeah huh keep it coming
I mean we have eventually they stopped
right um maybe and the winner is link
[Music]
hey i won you should I just did that's
right this one's like there's one of the
Eklund lifts out
ow all right don't get on arrows like
I've never really run out of arrows as
long you know you keep with it but they
do before you thought all right
baby there are long move along sir all
right to you what for we'll find out I
keep forgetting I think we were heading
to floor number nine oh yeah this is the
one else to go
who's well those guys called was a
Lazaro snow Wizards such as lizards I
believe it's just weird really take a
photo find out it'll last longer
wizzrobe whiz road I hear talking back
oh oh oh now it floats it was floating
oh yeah you're right
[Laughter]
whoa Jesus that was that possible sweet
oh and you get their magic from this too
right right there
because they're always pretty easy there
if they're fire or the speed of which
they like launch those things was was
faster maybe more frustrating he's got
lightning though which get up oh you've
done it now
he got these boomerangs are still so
gratifying either day I like made it my
mission to go get one of those giant
ones oh yeah those are trip yeah and
then when you first show me that
freeze oh [ __ ] I screwed that up
oh response oh that's right no I dropped
my stuff man
so you know what else he does and when
it went in my first place I took too
long to kill him and he spawned a
thunderstorm ah yeah I didn't have any
like I had wood weapons but like I don't
know like that scared me like imagine I
don't like maybe 25 when like that's all
you have that's scary I don't want to
think about it yeah and you see what
does majora's mask view the majora's
mask will essentially take place of
every monster mask except for the lionel
one and it'll let you walk up to most
common enemies and they won't fight you
be able just look Robert Thomas in the
chat says he he'd beat the master trial
Diddy what can you tell us Robert Thomas
what is the final battle actually I'm
imagining it's a gold liner or you
mentioned a like a one of the blights
right I think it's probably just Zelda
and you have to make the decision to
actually kill no I mean you couldn't
have the Master Sword if you really want
to but you have to kill me wink yeah
it's up to you whatever [ __ ] it's for
ten number ten this is not number ten my
favorite before I died on this floor
once all right
[Music]
yeah I'm confident I wanna rock these
guys it really need its face Thanks yeah
look good good go for it let's also
start off with a bang Oh and fall in the
water even more screwed yep that doesn't
do much to them cuz they love it they're
like yeah I needed that dip dog [ __ ] oh
ok Robert Thomas feet like you the first
part ok
like that
Oh No jinkies dude I see it I see it
[Music]
dang
Oh double dang oh he's find me
oh nice block that's a stain
damnit sorry dude
[Music]
god I hate their footsteps Tarr nice
time
[Music]
get up here just I killed that other one
[Music]
mm-hmm that wasn't too bad
[Music]
like you can it's that when there's
three of you or three of them on you
that's just like hectic so yeah like
you're definitely utilizing your
environment like yeah you mentioned
earlier like there's bombs up there you
could like sneak to
yep nailed it nailed it all right that's
it we are playing the switch version
we're streaming this just like you would
any other console you just pass HDMI to
a little device and hook it up to a PC I
know the ps4 lets you stream on the
bridge but can't do that with switch oh
yeah this one what is the deal with this
one
uh yeah let me explain there's a mob one
on the top and I feel like the best
approach is to get to him quicker so
how does he see me I mean you're the
only thing moving yes I face maybe I
went around Oh what his fire arrows
now we are coming up on the two and a
half hour mark are we feeling feeling
pretty good I feel like I'm doing better
now than was earlier rhythm [ __ ]
what's up with you Phil again
f0s day problem problem what is your
problem I don't know they're all alerted
last night my difference though real is
your electricity shock them yeah have a
nice swim nice in the face
Oh daddy's home
really yeah look over there
come on yeah I expected more [ __ ]
this game is [ __ ] oh did you hear
something come down here let's talk
[Applause]
nice flip mask for that oh that's oh my
god excuse me for yelling oh my god
that was a hit dude oh no I feel like
did you use an electricity it's gonna
make him drop his weapon so yeah yeah
you're really good with your right
[Music]
[Music]
yeah let season food I should I should
eat it all eat it all for you lose oh I
shouldn't that last I think I got this
get rid of a weapon you pick up his club
so he can't pick it back up [ __ ] my
heart was racing just then yeah yeah the
only things that Archer dam Archer
the only problem those I don't have much
health left
this guy killing sick I think I have a
crush on you I was [ __ ] hot it's it's
intense it's focus like system just
[ __ ] around in Hyrule alright I gotta
get more stuff
Oh chest there by everything fire arrows
Oh is there I got up there oh man I got
you something cool that should do it
I just did this it was awkward
I obviously can't burn oh it's metal you
can do that damn thing I know right
murdered they show that at the
Peter I'm a little nervous but you're
golden you're weird as I've ever seen 14
but I actually don't remember there
being 14 this is what 12 or 11 like I
feel like oh there's another chess jcd
one asking if I think there's gonna be
any areas on the map I and the next one
yeah like if you if you go to the west
side of the map there are there's like
it's it's basically the border of the
map mm-hmm but it shows like an area it
looks like you should be able to go up
to like it names it it's not like
outside of the border but you can't
climb up it like right there's like a
wall yeah I feel like there's gonna be
something there yeah I think loot
dungeon probably the area and where that
dungeon be if not a new area
I guess well if you think about like the
like this is about like the champions
right like isn't supposed to like a
prequel was that confirmed yeah like it
could just be like a time warp hell is
that like maybe it's like just not even
something in Hyrule inside the mound
someone say yeah like that's now you the
hope right like temor who's saying I
read it out of the UK he's always
suggesting oh well they should make a
Metroid in the style of Zelda where yes
you have the world on top but you also
have all the underground stuff and
things like in mountains from spork
that would be rad because right now you
can't really explore the inside of the
mountain too much right I threw the head
most you'll find the keys but it's small
it's like one room all right there's I
mean yeah there's so many opportunities
to like build this game out underground
like they meet the surface I just don't
know how extensive they're gonna do it
if they're gonna take that route at all
yeah
oh is that frickin Apple hell yeah hell
yeah oh is that another one hell yeah
well no it's not
Oh summarize we're not losing it yeah
would you do this you didn't have max
hearts or stamina dude you saw those
hits man yeah like oh I mean that
granted I did start with like four help
hearts missing true I think but still I
think it's gonna be a challenge oh yeah
that mean hits late-game challenge oh
this is it last one
Oh before it makes you rest
yeah this is the Latin literally last
thing so I don't know where I got 14
it's just 12 crap
yeah I'm not I don't think it's too bad
but you know now I think about it if he
hits me once hey what's up miss what's
her name lucario lucario which I like if
he hits me once I'm done right there's
got to be some palm fruit up here that's
what I'm trying to get but I got one
this one a pop right yeah that just
might save my life all right you can do
it put your back into it I'm just gonna
rock dude his world forget about your
health but I'm just gonna rock his world
with these guys okay yeah I mean I'm
shooting his eye anyway and using stasis
Oh sick Oh all right that's it
oh all right
wake up it's go time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] bad news
[Music]
you know what's the place for that he
wants to play ball like I don't want to
get near him right yeah he's got leg
bracings anyway like he really wants
that
[Music]
this is Bud who's a weak spot I don't
even know other than his eye tonight
[Music]
as for myself he's covering it so smart
[Music]
I just pray to God I don't run out of
arrows nope
[Music]
this is 1 over 12 right now this is the
last one of the beginner trials so
what's wrong this we're gonna jump out
and jump back in for one more to see how
the next batch starts off then we're
gonna call it a scream yeah it's been
going for almost three hours
[Music]
accidentally climb a tree
Oh
my tree Hey
yeah yeah there it is
good work that wasn't that bad you find
my work boy howdy
tell you what fighting him in your
underpants is not smart that's the only
choice we have it's such a good point
all right cool that was scary
but you do oh yeah this next part is see
this is a cool ass room oh hello right
I didn't get his gear it doesn't matter
it's the last one I wouldn't like
bringing in the back right where'd you
[ __ ] fell off here do it
no come on why not
no why not we're not gonna see the next
one okay
cool room then right
sweet sweet room oh yeah
[Music]
I can't screw this up Peter just just
hell no just do it
hell no right dude be naughty
come on oh you know I'm guessing is uh
so you probably come back here for the
second one and then the turd I mean so
it does it takes you out back to Caracas
now okay which I'm cool I'm cool with
that
how are you doing I'm losing it guys
look forward to playing this at home
yeah me too
we got 40 weekend coming up yeah I have
a wedding tomorrow I don't want to go
off the wedding honey could you do keys
like okay weirdo get out of here
[Music]
yes stuck arts this is essentially a
checkpoint BAM check a point music okay
cool need a minute one second
all right or Polly's flap we're go over
one more you know maybe it's all the way
to the right oh that's right link you
can't do it I do some bird you turned
out to be wish you could have these
wings huh all right let's eat and do
this so hopefully this works I'm pretty
sure it does so this is what we just
joining us we missed this a good trick
is to cook yeah basically two options
cook three mighty bananas with a mighty
this fizzle and dragon horn and you get
three attack up for 30 minutes late
wears it for three minutes 30 minutes
where is it where is it
I'm not gonna leave until I see it where
is it there it is there you go so that's
pretty cool pretty juicy and then you
can also do on the flip you do fortified
pumpkins and dragon horn and also before
I do the other precaution as you do this
gets some indirect carrots put those in
a pot baby you guys Sam in a cone just
came out from under you and I took it
you're good Elsa then also get some
Durin's durian durian durian durian
durian and then BAM now you're set now
I'm ready get in here oh you can go back
I even bother checking thank God thank
God I could do that again
let's go I'm ready
what what do you start from 13 the next
time so it's like a checkpoint exactly
oh did we answer that yeah I'll keep
looking at chat like 10 minutes after
that's cool that's cool that's a little
slow
whoa Chad did you hear that not like
like stupid slow I just feel like now is
called usedto no I'm not do how dad this
just got interesting
no man I just meant like no keeps keep
no you're in a roll oh speaking of
stupid Chet I just spend like the speed
speaking of interesting though he's he's
clarifying how slow you are how you want
more power huh
I'm sorry don't cry no one's listening
Rob I'm talking myself all right all
right voice I'm gonna set this to be my
alarm clock you will never wake I'm
sorry I'm in my nightmare clock alarm
I'm thinking a blood moon rises already
he sees me oh crap
don't have anything Oh God
and anything pray okay this is weird
oh don't spin off oh I should have done
that huh
you know it's interesting looking if I
get them to shoot me here
that bombs you know fly them out
oh sorry for yelling burn down the pub
yep this is not good but why would you
need to do that cuz you already on the
plaque oh worked no didn't why can't you
can't get to it now I don't think oh
you're too low is yeah
hey guys what's up Oh see that back I do
I do I do I do have a nice trip to hell
oh [ __ ]
come on you know it is that damn wind
yeah you're right I'm not an arrow
you see that
I don't to use my where'd it go nice but
how was it yeah oh no you want to keep
going we're only ten minutes away from
hitting two o'clock I'm down we'll do
one more yeah
all right let's do it I mean I don't
think I'm gonna get very far in this to
be completely honest but hey oh you have
no face damn it no this first one is
giving a lot of stuff
any other flying fruit uh yeah did they
show any images of fire excuse me um I'm
pointing this way in the virtual world
there is no the piece of food
when I saw something glowing
and any like promo images did they do
they show off any like as far as the
trials any like shots of Linc wearing
armor or anything like that I want to
say yes but yeah we're wondering the
same thing chat we're not sure about the
words yeah that's funny they just said
that they'd be cool to pick something up
yeah
there is a chess around here
oh I got I had a few oh you know I'm
going on a limb here I don't think the
horse can hear you keep something good
these shoes
next floor man are they all gonna be in
rooms like this I hope not it almost
makes your life easier in a sense though
because you have an escape yeah
yeah
when it was we got under there Oh what
on earth ha
Oh fire rod that's good build it dude
horrible shot me show you how it's done
names link what's your name
I think he's got a meteor great perfect
perfect just here right
hmm
[Music]
cool cool
another chest
all right it's not just one taco
you see one the only one I saw
let's go check out these bozos probably
switch bows
stay there box get my on you yeah oh
that's not good
oh you know I should have done was this
is a stick
I always forget you do that
so close looking with this get out
[Music]
Nathan says you gotta go commando for
this trail trial trail he wrote trail
okay oh good mate all right let's say we
got time for one more okay
and I'll have to finish up my desk
excuse me yeah I'm realizing that we
actually need to eat food
yes max we'll get you something about
that box
hello this is a supporting platforms
that makes sense right are gonna be in
hard night oh yeah tight oh that's
pretty good
this poor guy got the worst oh [ __ ] what
oh my god that took a while
gage
oh yeah that was good one thank I give
it to you Wow how did that happen I
guess there's a all right yeah bomber
it's a bad time for you oh oh oh oh
hello there goes everything yep saving
that one is not gonna hit them again oh
my god
what's up I can't see me that's not oh
my god okay
let's get out of here all right that's
it
probably should go for this guy first
like that
no-no-no having to probably this you
should probably all right call it yeah
yeah guys sir we have to call it but I
imagine at some point someone here will
have completed trial the sword I'm sure
it'll be you I'm Shelby tonight
that's why why you say thanks for
sticking with us everyone this has been
robbed kicking ass in the news all the
DLC
I've been Peter Evan your co-host and
with any luck we'll be back doing some
more master mode stuff next week so have
a good weekend enjoy your 4th of July
absolutely thank you so much for
watching yeah and do give us a like and
sub if you enjoyed this because it helps
us down the road 90 core content you can
find me on Twitter at PC and Rob at
Robert and Lori it's my full name
perfect alright thanks everyone take
care see you guys bye bye